you're walking around downtown among the
beautiful historic buildings each of
them is unique with different colors and
ornaments you then turn a corner and oh
it's one of those newly built areas full
of sterile non-descript boxes gone is
the charm the atmosphere and the
character of the Lively Historic
downtown it's only sterilized cultural
Dead Zone you press Zone and eventually
reach the office area which is even
worse even the meager individual
characteristics of those new residential
blocks are gone it's all just a bunch of
glass cubes how depressing that's it I
can't take this anymore I need to go to
the store to get myself a oh God wait a
sec you know those old beautiful Market
Halls people used to shop in well now
it's all big metal boxes what is going
on here why do all new buildings look so
Bland and depressing compared to the old
ones how come we don't build quote
unquote beautiful buildings anymore
let's find out the Story begins in the
late 19th early 20th century
architectural Styles like neoclassical
were still widespread in the developed
world but a new movement was emerging
modernism hit the architectural scene
its main tenets are minimalism the
rejection of ornament and the idea that
form should follow function ah so that's
why we don't build nice buildings
anymore those stupid talentless
progressives back then came up with
their stupid soulless architectural
style and forced it upon the world so
now all new buildings are ugly right no
it's a decent plot for a Disney movie
but reality is a bit more complex I'm
afraid see modernism care about in an
era of technological Revolution new and
Innovative building materials like glass
and steel and reinforced concrete
enabled buildings never before seen or
even thought possible examples of
modernist architecture include the
Sydney Opera House the Empire State
Building and this little known Landmark
called the Eiffel Tower a big part of
the reason why modernism got so popular
is that after so many years of dominance
by the old people were simply ready for
something new instead of Stuffy stuck up
over decorated buildings we had Falling
Water Villa tugentad pale de chayu the
Rockefeller Center and a whole lot more
fresh and modern buildings you wouldn't
unironically put on the 17th century
outfit for your job interview would you
now you will go for a relatively
minimalistic yet elegant suit or a dress
because well because 17th century guards
just aren't the thing nowadays the idea
is the same with building ornamentation
changing tastes throughout the times
however there are some additional far
more interesting reasons and before we
get into those I'd like to thank
athletic greens for a spot
I'd like to thank athletic greens for
sponsoring today's video and sending me
a full package of ag1 to try ag1 is a
whole food Dieter supplement for daily
use containing 75 vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients to help
cover your body's daily needs it's
gluten and dairy free low calorie and
vegan ag1 is unique as currently there
is hardly a more comprehensive
supplement on the market and it's made
with the highest quality ingredients
it's easy to mix has a mild Pleasant
taste and a nice texture if you made a
New Year's resolution of say getting in
shape or getting healthier ag1 will help
you achieve your goals it's February
still so hey you're not too late AG
won't support your immune system
maintains your energy level and boosts
your body's natural recovery process
personally ever since I started drinking
ag1 in the morning I found that I no
longer need coffee to start my day and I
feel generally more alert and clearer in
the head all in all I'm satisfied with
ag1 and can genuinely recommend it to my
viewers get yourself a pack of ag1 using
the link in the description and enjoy
its benefits to your mind and body now
thank you for checking out ag1 by
athletic greens Edge like this support
me in creating more content for you and
now back to the video so as we discussed
a reason why buildings nowadays have
less ornaments is changing tastes
throughout the times now this is all
well and good but it doesn't explain
save Soviet apartment blocks or similar
large-scale public housing virtually
nobody finds these buildings good
looking or interesting so there must be
something else in the background other
than changing tastes there is an idea in
far-right conspiracy circles that
actually modern architecture is a plot
by the shadowy elites to crush the
spirit of white civilization so they can
import non-white into developed
countries to dilute the culture and the
white gene pool because of reasons and
this might be an interesting plot for a
South Park episode but as usual reality
is a bit more complicated do comic
blocks and similar large-scale public
housing projects look sometimes Bland or
uninspiring sure but they weren't built
as a form of architectural expression
they were simply not made to look
beautiful in Europe following World War
II there was a massive housing crisis
basically everywhere so States set up
massive public housing programs in the
Soviet sphere of influence this was done
via soccer old house factories where
they mass produced standardized elements
that workers could put together on site
thus massive amounts of housing could be
built at a low cost relatively quickly
and it worked combing blocks essentially
solved the housing crisis and for a time
anyway they also represented a
civilizational shift for their new
inhabitants who often moved in from
buildings without electricity or indoor
plumbing if you want to know more about
comic blocks I have a whole video about
them feel free to check it out so next
time you hear someone say that public
housing apartment blocks are a communist
plot to crush the human Spirit or
something while being homeless or not
having access to running water or
perhaps bigger threats to human Spirit
who knows also imagine if some local
government spent its public housing
money on ornamentation instead of
building as many units as possible hello
citizens we only Built seven blocks out
of 10 due to higher element costs so
hundreds of you will not have a roof
over your heads but hey look how
beautiful these seven blocks are now
you'll have something nice to look at
from under the bridge so there's our
second reason why we don't always build
nice buildings housing shortages but
this still doesn't explain this latest
onslaught of same-looking buildings in
the US and Europe such buildings are
absolutely everywhere and spreading
they're Bland and boring uninspired
depressing and so on though to be fair
the US is more affected by this than
Europe so why do developers keep
spamming these buildings it's not like
they're part of a massive standardized
public housing project we're living
under neoliberal capitalism which
happens to be the reason why those
buildings look the way they look you see
from the late 20th century onward
housing was increasingly looked at not
as spaces to live but its Commodities to
be bought and sold this culminated in
the 2000s housing bubble and the
consequent 2008 economic crisis people
simply stopped planning for durability
quality and proper Aesthetics just get
the cheapest materials you can put up a
building that looks reasonably nice and
sell it at inflated prices due to their
low quality construction the buildings
will start falling apart in a few years
but it doesn't matter since by then you
will have already made your money and
the building would be on its seventh
owner who is looking to sell it at an
even higher price housing went from
places to live to a speculation scheme a
hot potato match among investors but
when the music stopped everyone went
bankrupt aside from outright speculation
there is also the good old-fashioned
profit motive let's take a developer who
wants to put up a new building to rent
or sell the units suppose we present
them with architectural templates
neoclassical Art Deco Baroque Revival
and the average 5 over 1. 10 times out
of 10 they'll pick the five over one
ending door to rest why because it's the
cheapest Ergo will make the most money
with it turns out five over ones are
built using standardized materials that
can be mass produced keeping costs down
even if the quality is questionable well
it only needs to hold together till the
end of the warranty period then it's the
new owner's problem or in case of
renting developers can just keep blaming
the tenants for defects and deduct
repairs from their deposits a developer
could spend the boatload of money on a
durable brick neoclassical apartment
building with tons of ornamentation but
that won't affect the rent or unit price
all that much since the three most
important aspects of real estate or
location location and location if you
are a developer building units in a
desirable location as long as the units
are most inhabitable that's all you need
really you'll have made your money this
story is the same with Office Buildings
and large shopping centers as we do not
mass-produce classical ornaments they
would need to be custom made for each
building at prohibitive costs but how
come companies don't want to build
something representative still why
aren't say Walmart's built nice like
those Old Market halls with that we
arrive at the fourth factor and what
would that be recently the beautiful art
Novi fasado Prague main station was
renovated the station regained its
former splendor but almost nobody
noticed because no one is there to see
it because there's an urban freeway and
an elevated parking lot right in front
of it if you want to experience the for
someone's architectural Beauty you have
to crawl through dark piss smelling
underpasses and grimy rusted spiral
stairs and stand in the middle of a
concrete parking lot next to an urban
freeway hardly a conducive environment
for savoring the Arts core centered
areas actively sabotage architectural
Beauty why would anyone bother building
something good looking or waste money an
ornamentation when no one will be around
to appreciate it even if you build a
good-looking Walmart that isn't just a
big metal box who cares people will just
park their cars Scurry inside do their
show shopping and then drive away nobody
stays around the stroll to talk to hang
out to take in the beauty around them
what could is a beautiful building when
your city is built for cars cars don't
appreciate architectural Beauty people
do but for that they have to be around
and if roads in your city look like this
and sound like this
nobody will stick around in which case
why even bother building anything nice
aside from Urban motor traffic parking
minimums are also to blame here those
old atmospheric human-centric beautiful
areas would be illegal to build today
due to parking requirements the current
laws in much of the world actually
prescribe core infested cities and force
developers to build a ton of parking for
new buildings which then induces even
more car traffic and drives up
construction costs thus areas become
congested thus there will be less people
hanging around and suddenly you don't
need to build anything good looking
anymore people will be looking at the
road in front of them not at the
buildings and even if a developer wanted
to pay for ornamentation despite
everything well unfortunately the
underground garage they were forced to
build due to parking minimums ate all
their ornament money but hey at least
Karen can comfortably Park her rezvani
Vengeance SUV equipped with bulletproof
glass explosive underbody Shield
electrified door handles built-in pepper
spray and a loudspeaker
so to answer the question of why we
don't build a corner called Beautiful
buildings anymore and by that people
colloquial I mean ornamented pre-modern
buildings the reasons we've pinpointed
are as follows day is changing with the
times sheer necessity to House people
housing becoming a commodity instead of
places to live and course-centric urban
planning so next time you see a new
quote-unquote ugly building you'll know
why it's there no conspiracy just taste
necessity capitalism or cars and this is
not to say we stopped building nice
things beauty can come from places other
than ornament take the three biggest
stations in
budapesti are beautiful but so is daily
just in a different way and personally
deal is my favorite of them all anyway
there was my excuse to talk about rail
thank you for watching if you appreciate
my content consider supporting me on
patreon so I can make more content like
this and I'll be seeing you next time